I wrote it, I sent it, I'm ****d
- So a few years ago,
in a little apartment
in West Hollywood,
I was having trouble sleeping.
(cartoon blinks)
So I was prescribed Ambien.
(thud)
Then I discovered if I stayed up
just a little bit
past when I should,
I became someone my
friends fondly named--
- [Voiceover] Jambien.
- Now Jambien loved
to call people,
she loved to play her
ukulele and sing for people,
she loved to eat.
But in the rare occasion
there wasn't enough food
in the fridge and there was
nobody answering their phone,
she would send text
messages, she would tweet,
and she would post at
people's Facebook pages.
All of these have been erased
in protection of Jamie,
but this Facebook post:
"U are something else okay.
"Just feed me tomorrow morn...
"O-kay?
"I want to screens it all
"and set a pop tart
in my mouth to eat.
"It is T-J, R-E,
"K-W," which I think
meant can't wait,
"for this to happen
ohzz and it will.
"The whoo, whoo bandit.
"Toldja she'd be behind it all.
"K bye."
The Who-Who Bandit is somebody
apparently I tweeted about,
about 30 to 40 times.
I have no idea who that is,
it's the alternative universe
that Jambien lives in.
I've retired from
my Jambien days,
at least for the time being.
Pro tip: if you've
always wondered
who your alter ego
is, take Ambien.